networking is a thrilling career path
that holds immense potential for growth
and personal fulfillment it is a gateway
to Connecting People ideas and
technology in an Ever evolving and
digital world by diving into the realm
of networking you Embark a journey where
you become a catalyst for Innovation
enabling businesses to thrive and
individuals to flourish in the realm of
networking you possess the power to
bring Bridges Forge Partnerships and
bring together diverse Minds you become
an architect of connectivity creating
seamless communication channels that
transcend borders and Empower
collaboration on a global scale your
expertise in networking opens doors to
exciting opportunities whether it's
designing robust infrastructures
optimizing data flow or safeguarding
critical systems with each technological
advancements networking profession
display a vital role in shaping the
future you have the chance to be at the
Forefront of groundbreaking
Transformations such as rise of 5G the
internet of things and ongoing digital
Revolution a career in networking
empowers you to make real difference
shape the future and be an integral part
of the digital transformation
welcome to the exciting world of
networking where connections bring
possibilities to life get ready to
unlock the secrets of seamless
communication and become a master of
digital realm in today's hyper-connected
world networking is the backbone that
keeps businesses thriving individuals
connected and Innovation flowing it's
the magic that brings together people
devices and information transforming the
way we live work and play in this
tutorial video we will unveil the power
and potential of networking and why it's
a skill you absolutely must learn but
before we begin if these are the type of
videos you would like to watch then hit
on the Subscribe button and click the
Bell to never miss an update from Simply
learn and if you are someone who is
interested in building a career in cyber
security by graduating from the best
universities or a professional who Alex
to switch careers with cyber security by
learning from the experts then giving a
shot to Simply launch postgraduate
program in cyber security from
schwarzman's College of computing in
collaboration with EC Council the link
in the description box should navigate
you to the home page where you can find
a complete overview of the program being
offered take action upskill and get
ahead without further Ado let's get
started with understanding why you must
learn networking to begin with why do
you need to learn networking we need to
dig down and understand the importance
various domains on networking networking
is closely related to other it domains
and plays a crucial role in their
successful operation
here are a few ways networking
intersects with other it rules such as
system administration cyber security
cloud computing devops and data center
management we will understand each one
of these in detail first system
administration Network administrators
work closely with system administrators
to ensure that the network
infrastructure supports the smooth
functioning of the systems and
applications they collaborate on tasks
such as network configuration security
measures and troubleshooting Network
related issues next we have cyber
security networking and cyber security
go hand in hand network security
Specialists focus on protecting the
network infrastructure from unauthorized
access malware and other security
threats they work alongside cyber
Security Professionals to implement
security measures monitor Network
traffic and respond to incidents
followed by that we have clocked
Computing networking is an essential
component of cloud computing Cloud
Architects and Engineers design and
manage Network architectures that
facilitate the security and efficient
transfer of data between cloud services
own promises infrastructure and end
users next ahead we have devops
networking plays a crucial role in
devops practices where development and
operations team collaborate closely
Network Engineers work with devops
professionals to design and deploy
networks that support continuous
integration and delivery or CI CD
pipelines ensuring efficient deployment
and operational software applications
followed by that we have data center
management networking is vital for data
centers which house critical ID
infrastructure Network Engineers
collaborate with data center managers to
design Implement and maintain robust
network architectures with data center
environments enabling seamless
connectivity and efficient data transfer
networking is an integral part of it
ecosystem collaborating with various
roles to enable efficient communication
secure data transfer and reliable system
operation apart from these there are
many compelling reasons why you should
give a shot to learning the fundamentals
of networking following reasons are
first High On Demand networking skills
are on high demand offering excellent
job prospects and long-term career
scalability followed by that we have
technological innovation networking is
the Forefront of technological
advancements providing opportunities to
work with Cutting Edge Technologies and
shape the future next ahead we have the
global connectivity networking enables
you to connect with people businesses
and ideas on global scale fostering
collaborations and making a tangible
impact on the society next on the docket
is continuous learning the field of
networking is dynamic and ever evolving
offering constant learning opportunities
to stay ahead of the curve and expand
your skill set and lastly we have
competitive Advantage possessing strong
Network skills give you a Competitive
Edge as businesses rely on reliable and
secure networks to thrive in the digital
age having known about the importance
and reasons to learn networking let's
proceed with the most important aspect
of networking as a career that is salary
of a network engineer entry-level
networking engineers in the United
States of America can earn an annual
salary ranging from 50 000 to 90 000 per
annum whereas on the senior level the
senior networking Engineers or those in
leadership positions can earn salaries
exceeding 120
000 to 150 000 or more an entry level
networking engineer in India can expect
to earn an annual salary around 6 to 12
tax per annum a senior of Highly
experienced Network Engineers can earn
salaries ranging from 12 lakhs to 20
lakhs per annum some of the top
companies hiring Network Engineers
include the following entity Cisco TCS
HCL IBM HP Accenture and web Pro before
we end this video let's take a minute to
hear from our Learners who have
experienced massive success and their
careers
[Music]
foreign
to learn anything new whether it's an
art a new language a new sport or
learning new skills to advance your
career hi I'm Phillip I'm 61 years old
and last year I upskilled with simply
learns post-graduate program in cyber
security after working 30 years in the
I.T sector in various different profiles
I'm happy to tell you that I was able to
clear and pass my cissp and ccsp
certification exams on the first attempt
after taking the course funny story I
want to share with you
I started off as fine to be a DJ where I
became interested in electronic stereo
systems and how they connected and how
they operate and what made them function
and four years ago I began a journey to
understand and learn more about the
cloud on the way I develop a natural
understanding of the security needs and
began to focus my studies to understand
more about the cyber security aspect of
the cloud landscape
I work with many companies before the
security analyst and the architect on a
contract basis but I needed some
stability which I got with the job I
just started with Infosys as a cyber
security consultant happened after I
took the course I've been an adjunct
faculty member at Prince George in
college and been in many different
learning and training experiences but
the experience as a student is simply
learning something I will always cherish
of course I must say was packed with
practical examples it was led by highly
skilled certified instructors that I
believe in living a fulfilling life at
61. I am still trained students in
martial arts I've been practicing
martial arts for the past 40 years and
my efforts were acknowledged by the
Eastern United States International
Martial Arts Association
where I was inducted into the Hall of
Fame for a lifetime achievement of
dedication service to the martial arts
I've been many things in my life first
and foremost I've been a learner be a
learner first
that we have been to the end of this
tutorial on why learn networking if you
have any questions please feel free to
leave us a comment and we will have it
answered for you at the old list until
next time thank you for watching stay
safe keep learning and get ahead
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign